belle bonjou base à toutes vont vous
fait des dégâts et puis j'ai mis tout
edmond mondésir bonjour bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes ici dans ce studio ce
matin en tant que porte parole du cncp
on va pelle que ça veut dire comité
national des conseillers conseil conseil
national des comités populaires où elle
a fait la nation voilà donc c'est bien
conseil national des comités populaires
alors on sait que ce parti a connu une
scission il ya quelques années vous on
peut dire vous êtes de la tendance
grands ensembles et 1 ou à pales puisque
le nouveau slogan c'est assez plairait
en nullité la dénomination exacte c'est
cncp mouvement assez pléré annou lité
voilà donc qui a suivi la démarche des
alliances qui nous a amenés au gua sable
et voilà au grand semblait très bien
vous avez bien résumé ça alors comment
envisagez-vous au cncp tendance anglais
éviter que sa pâle comme envisagées vont
au cnc paix appelle le rendez vous
électoral des municipales en mars
prochain edmond mondésir
et il faut dire que pour nous les
élections municipales représentent un
moment qui est qui est intéressant parce
que ça peut être un terrain pour
développer l'unité des patriotes parce
que c'est le lieu où on peut essayer de
faire des alliances et de se rencontrer
mais c'est aussi un cadre pour
développer une connaissance concrète
pour aider des problématiques auxquelles
on est confronté comme angers à sa toute
une série de problèmes de ce genre mais
pour nous pas pour la caractéristique de
leur mouvement
c'est une dimension assez profondes pour
pouvoir améliorer la perception et la
compréhension que nous avons ce qu'on
appelle la démocratie
ça veut dire que la démocratie ce pas au
moment des élections pour choisir la
personne c'est à 20 après pendant parce
qu'on est obligé de se mettre ensemble
pour construire des solutions donc pour
ça nous avons décidé de mettre en oeuvre
une démarche d'alliance qui nous a mené
à ces choses là et les autres tout cas
nous avons des personnes que nous avons
un don ne place pas aux abois fort de
france une conseillère municipale la
personne de monique pamphile la montée
un conseil municipal à la personne et 10
au tollé
à sainte luce aussi à la personne de
jean tremblay cibler les retours que
nous avons nous permettre de confirmer
cela que il s'agit de choses
intéressantes pour comprendre comment se
passent les problèmes étudie la question
des alliances etc
alors est-ce que vous allez figuré d'une
façon ou d'une autre pour ses prochaines
municipales
voilà alors est ce que ce sera sur des
listes en association en alliance avec
d'autres alliances à l'échelle communale
municipal ou est-ce que ici ou là vous
avez l'intention de présenter une liste
avec un candidat ou une candidate cncp
apal en tête
alors on ne part pas de rien toute une
histoire derrière donc pas qu'on sait
qu'on va maintenir les alliances qu'on
avait déjà donc à fort de france
nous étions en alliance avec les rieurs
fassis carole da faut que ça change et
fo de france c'est ce qui a amené
d'ailleurs ce qui est monique panfilo
pensée et municipal de fort de france et
je vous ai dit on a tiré un bilan très
intéressant de ces démarches et nous a
fait un petit peu le rapport de tout ça
et au lamentin nous allons rester dans
la démarche aussi conserve a déjà initié
et nous allons soutenir fabrice du nom
donc fois-ci scarole à fort de france
fabrice tenons la montée nous sommes
impliqués dans dans cette démarche-là et
l'idée pour nous c'est évidemment un peu
en fonction de l'analyse des situations
de voir sur quel lieu à quel endroit
nous allons porter nos efforts ou à voix
nue si vous voulez quelque chose
d'intéressant à schoelcher par exemple
on sait que le saint céré est bien
implanté oui les 2 sont là et c'est ça
c'est ça médecin îles à sion de monsieur
mettrait la voile alors voilà maintenant
il n'est pas obligatoire que partout
vous ayez la prétention de présenter des
candidats partout il faut faire une
analyse je crois que tout le monde fait
des analyses en fonction de la situation
et décide de porter ces efforts là aussi
le plus intéressant parce que notre
peuple mouvement n'a pas une vocation
non plus spécial si vous voulez à
investir partout des candidats par
contre quand il ya une grande dimension
d'éducation de formation parce que nous
pensons que le paiement dénigrer pour
avancer leur pouvoir faire des
expériences intéressantes
je vous en donne une l'expérience
intéressante
les employés fort de france à la base
dans les relations qui a entre les
conseillers municipaux et bien ya
quelque chose d'intéressant que ça
apporte et on parle souvent de minorité
majorité ou bien d'opposition mais en
fait la démocratie c'est l'apport de
tous et de chacun pour créer un échange
propice à ce que la l'intérêt général
soient mises en oeuvre
nous avons des retours aussi hausse à
fort de france mais j'ai pas venu trop
de détails mirent à sainte-luce au
lamentin et donc c'est ça qui nous
intéresse que la politique servent à
rendre meilleur le citoyen de dire que
le bateau mais aussi créer des relations
plus profondes entre les gens alors
précisément
est ce que ce type de rendez vous
électoral c'est pas aussi l'occasion de
poser un regard particulier sur
l'aménagement du territoire global en
martinique wii et sur le développement
encore assez inégal finalement ici ou là
entre zones géographiques
on pense donc le nord le centre et au
sud par exemple mais dans certains cas
même il ya des disparités parfois assez
marquées entre des des communes voisines
ou proches dans un même secteur dans une
même communauté d'agglomération par
exemple est-ce que à l'occasion
justement de huy où ils se disent c'est
pas seulement à l'occasion elle et ça
correspond à une perspective on va dire
ben lauga globale s'ils ont un temps
très long parce que dans ces domaines-là
aménager le territoire développer des
endroits et c'est la chose que nous
avons pu apprendre de notre
fréquentation de ce domaine c'est qu'on
ne décide pas d'un coup de baguette
magique de transformer les choses et une
série de conditions qui doivent être
mises en oeuvre
alors pour vous dire nous sommes très
contents que l'expérience que nous avons
commencé en 2004 banner alias avec le
mime au bout de dix ans en 2015 est
amené à ceux ci une modification on
avait deux instances concernées à ces
régionales et pour que le territoire
soit développe de façon équilibrée
il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose de
central et d'organiser dans une première
étape
ensuite il ya les différentes étapes
qu'on va mettre en oeuvre par exemple
les questions de transport de manière
très concrète
pour que les territoires puissent être
en relation parce que les gens puissent
se développer vous avez une 1ère chose
fondamentale c'est de permettre un
transport soit facilitée parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez très bien que
les systèmes d'embouteillage clés liées
à la voiture individuelle et tout ça
crée des difficultés considérables
pouvoir et ont prouvé les choses comme
ça donc en fait oui 30 loto un pays at
il ajouté en boucle dans le chercher le
le refrain oui alors je disais
précisément que l'objectif de la pensée
politique moderne
elle se base sur deux choses
essentielles que nous avons réussi a
fait en martinique un land irréversible
l'identité martiniquaise
c'est irréversible maintenant on a gagné
ça c'est clair c'est toute la société
martiniquaise terminé la deuxième chose
la conscience de la nécessité de mettre
en atouts en avant nos atouts
le domaine de la culture domaine de la
production si vous voulez pour
l'autoconsommation mais domaine de la
mise en oeuvre nos technologies et de
nos un générique moderne
donc si on est capable de mettre tout ça
en oeuvre on pourra agir nous mêmes sur
les déséquilibres dont vous parlez alors
vous avez fait allusion plusieurs fois
justement à cette alliance du grand
semblait alors d'abord alliance avec le
mime et puis quelques autres partis
notamment par exemple le rdm mai mais
aussi actuellement à la collectivité
territoriale de martini qui on sait bien
que ces municipales et communautaires
sont un peu un tour de un tour de
chauffe pour les élections justement
régional enfin territoriale de l'année
suivante donc 2021 de ce point de vue là
est ce que
vous ferez une analyse critique un bilan
sérieux sans concession je veux dire de
votre alliance au grand semblait y
compris donc avec des élus issus par
exemple de l air donc je pense à vih ans
tout ça notamment la droite parce que
certains dans le camp souverainiste ou
indépendantistes vous reproche cette
alliance voici voici le bilan de gestion
à la ctm cette partie là de l'échiquier
politique voici le bilan en 2004 union
avec le mime victoire parce que ici en
martinique on a souvent l'habitude de
considérer que les événements les plus
importants c'est un bon nous avons eu
des défaites ou des choses comme ça
j'entends des gens parler de 2009 comme
quelque chose de une défaite alors que
en 59 a eu des choses et et en 2009 un
mois de mouvement tout ça et c'est nous
n'ayons pas trop donc ce qui veut dire
que nous avons obtenu un bilan
extraordinaire 2000 toits en attente et
les volets institutionnels sap a eu lieu
à saint ouen mis au travail de 2000
canela il faudra faire le bilan la deûle
et le violacé le bilan c'est le suivant
avec le bal c'est le suivant le bilan
c'est le suivant nous avons réussi à
martinez 4 quelque chose qui paraissent
impossibles unir une quantité de
personnes peut obtenir que la matinée
que le droit de voter pour elle même un
dispositif pour corriger quelque chose
qui nous posait problème les deux
assemblées on l'a fait ensemble
le rassemblement martiniquais pour le
changement rmc
ça a été ça après évidemment comme dans
tous les cas lorsqu'il faut évidemment
si vous voulez aller un peu plus loin
tout ça tout le monde n'est pas à cela
même position c'est clair mais on a fait
ça aujourd'hui quelle est la deuxième
caractéristique c'est que il faut aller
plus loin maintenant qu'on a opéré le
changement on est en a maintenant une
ctm tout ça il faut passer à la
réalisation concrète de ce que je me
disais tout à l'heure
mettre en oeuvre les dispositifs qui
nous permettront d'aller plus loin et
donc de ce point de vue là c'est vrai
que la situation est le chant et en
changer les gens se disposent de façon
différente mais nous nous sommes fidèles
à l'alliance que nous avions mise en
oeuvre qu'elle nous a permis de
constater qu'on a pu avancer avec
alors on parle vous ne regrettez rien et
mais nous sommes très contents d'avoir
fait cette démarche parce que nous
sommes fiers de savoir que parmi les
dispositions institutionnelles la
martinique
celle-là la ctm et les dates une volonté
des martiniquais validée par un vote des
martiniquais et la mise en place d'une
d'une équipe qui a réalisé un contrat de
gestion qui dépassait les espèce de
clivage qu'on avait avant qui l'empêché
de mettre en avant les compétences les
qualités les expertises de chacun
merci est de mon désir d'avoir été donc
ça ou qu'a dit ce matin bonne journée à
toutes et à tous